en tout cas c'est un homme réfléchi
parce que avec ce que nous avons vécu
avec ma famille
j'aurais dû normalement on pourrait
imaginer que je sois du côté du oui
parce que j'ai perdu ma grand-mère qui
rend très fatigué à l'hôpital qui
n'avait pas l'accord vide et qui n'en
est jamais sortie puisque au bout de dix
jours d'hospitalisation à la trappe et
la commune à l'hôpital
donc je pourrais si je m'en tenais à ce
qui m'a touché dans ma chair plus
profond de moi
moi j'étais le premier petit fils un peu
de ma grammaire cessé il ya des
histoires qui marque néanmoins j'ai
répondu nombre pour pour deux raisons
majeures
d'abord une raison philosophique et une
raisons sanitaires
la raison philosophique
concerne le fait que j'ai du mal
philosophiquement parlant à prêter et à
mépriser et a pointé du doigt des femmes
et des hommes que j'ai érigé un héros au
plus fort de la crise j'ai du mal à me
dire qu'aujourd'hui
je vais faire partie de ceux
qui
vont avalisé la perte de salaire de
vanessa et d'autre et même s ils ne sont
pas nombreux puisque au nombre de 2 à 3%
semble-t-il d'après les études qui
remonte il ya deux millions sept cent
mille personnes qui sont concernées par
cette vaccination obligatoire si on
intègre les pompiers et autres et y a
que deux ou trois pourcent des personnes
qui ne le sont pas vaccinés et moi j'ai
pas en glisser deux ou trois pourcent de
les mettre au pilori sur le plan
philosophique je les applaudis à 21 et
leur reprocher un manque d'éthique que
je trouve que c'est mais d'un culot
monstrueux est ce qu on leur reprocher
un manque d'éthique lorsqu'ils n'avaient
pas de masque pas de blouse pas de garde
et que certains d'entre eux sont morts
de la commune parce qu'ils y étaient au
contact de patients qui leur a transmis
a commis on l'aura pas parler d'éthique
là il était en première ligne dans le
radial esi ne vous prenez pas question
on a besoin de vous parce qu'à la fin
c'est en train de craquer dans tous les
sens et ils ont été au rendez vous ça
c'est la raison philosophique ça c'est
la raison philosophique sur le pain
sanitaires si on m'avait assuré
tom vaccinez vous ne pouviez pas être
contaminé et contaminant
j'aurais pu comprendre cette obligation
aujourd'hui vanessa va au travail avec
un test pcr négatif sa collègue des
vaccinés elle n'a pas besoin de tests
pcr négatif ça coince sa collègue peut
être porteuse du virus et le transmettre
un malade mais n'est râble alors que l
avec son test pcr négatif on est certain
qu'elle ne l'a pas non n'est pas certain
qu'il
vous plaît
je
trouvais pas je vais te faire plaisir on
n'est pas certain pour vanessa vous êtes
certain pour la personne d'actionner non
quand moi
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que
philosophiquement j'ai un problème mais
il n'est pas comment dirais-je je
n'arrive pas à l'effacer par là que par
la raison sanitaire scolarisons
sanitaire ne me donne pas suffisamment
d'arguments pour dire à vanessa vanessa
tu déconnes en n'étant pas vacciner tu
peux tu peut contaminer quelqu'un comme
ma grand-mère d'accord et aujourd'hui je
peux pas lui dire parce qu'elle va me
reconnais que ma collègue qui est
vaccinés ont contaminé quelqu'un comme
ça de ma mère je vais lui dire quoi non
tu mens alors c'était en vérité leur
répond jfj altermind et j'en termine
parce que quand on parle parle de cette
émission on apprend une fois père
pendant l'essai autres moi je laisse les
autres par les jeunes écoutent pas j'en
termine j'ai l'impression et c'est ça
qui me fait du mal monsieur le député
vous devriez être un peu plus modeste
je me je vous le dis avec beaucoup
d'amitié
j'ai l'impression que ce monde d'après
son plan sanitaire
il est peut-être pire que le monde
d'avant ou nourrir pourquoi
avant la crise on avait un personnel
soignant qui décide et qui avait du mal
à être entendu par les pouvoirs publics
on a été frappée au coeur de la crise
ils ont été présents même si on l'avait
pas tenu on se rend compte qu'après la
crise ont néanmoins une dolly qu'on en
avait avant on n'a pas plus de personnel
en effectif ils sont pas me payer le
monde a pris les devants mais moi je
peux pas besoin du personnel qui moi
j'en connais du cou qui sont vaccinés et
qui me disent je n'ai qu'une envie
maintenant avec cette obligation c'est
de m'en aller oui ça m'a écoeuré
[Applaudissements]